hello I'm the Nostalgia guy remember so
you don't have to we've all seen people
have heart attacks on message boards
forums or even sometimes in person a lot
of people view George Lucas as the
Antichrist about what many of us think
are just the stupidest things
comic books TV shows and closest to my
heart movies people throw insults back
and forth they scream and yell even some
of the world's most famous critics got
in battles over images and sounds
projected on a screen my fucking movie
was awful don't ride Red Bull a rifle
Roger this man what happened to your
sense of humor can't talk about it can't
talk about so why do we get so emotional
over fictional media why do we get so
invested in something we know doesn't
exist and on top of that
should we when is it right to say this
is a horrible representation of
something important and why is it right
to say it's only a movie
when film first began nobody look to
critique it or analyze its storytelling
elements they were just too blown away
by how powerful the illusion was of
course over time as we got used to that
illusion we've done better to analyze
the impact films could have on us
we got invested in people's stories and
even hidden meanings Charles Foster Kane
walking in front of a mirror isn't just
Charles Foster Kane walking in front of
a mirror it can be a visual symbol of
the empty abyss that's reflected back to
him during such a dark period of his
life but from another point of view it
very well can be just a guy walking in
front of a mirror that's what makes film
such a great art form it can be both
film can be whatever you want it to be
with that said though is it really worth
getting so angry over someone's
fictional portrayal of something when
you get down to it it's not hurting you
that's good as 3d as gand it's yet to
actually leap out of the screen and beat
the shit out of you but of all
characters Ebenezer Scrooge from the
jorssy Scott version of Christmas Carol
brings up this interesting reball but
not a real child to talk to not a living
person
Robinson Crusoe not real and Friday the
parrot green body and yellow tail not
real
that's very true the pen can be mightier
than the sword stories can change our
minds and shape who we are in a bizarre
way we see much more truth and fiction
than we do in reality it takes our lives
which have no writers and tries to give
great understanding and even purpose to
them and that's something to greatly
admire and learn from when is the line
between fiction and reality too blurred
what does a character become too real
sure people dress up like famous
fictional icons and even make up worlds
to visit play and pretending but they
still come back to reality what about
those who let the illusion consume them
you know who I'm talking about we've
seen many instances both with movies and
online worlds where people choose to
give up on reality and instead live in
the fictional realm either someone else
has created or they create themselves it
becomes a problem when you ignore your
first life and many would say as long as
it's not hurting anyone why can't
someone just shut themselves in their
rooms never come out and live in the
fictional world of middle-earth avatar
or their own creations
after all movies games and any sort of
fiction is just a means to escape
reality right well as popular as that
argument is I strongly disagree with it
the purpose of fiction is to help us
understand reality not escape it it's
giving into a different time and place
to help you understand life lessons we
give into the world of Oz to realize
there's no place like home
we give in to the world of no country
for old men to realize the darkness of
the human mind might be getting even
emptier there's so many different
lessons in different ways to learn them
even journeys that seem to have no point
like in some comedies or even a few
video games they serve as an outlet to
get a few laughs or a little bit of fun
at the time tying back to the illusion
helping you in real life not abandoning
your life or the illusion playing the
game and getting your art going makes
you realize you need a little excitement
in your life and laughing at the
misfortunes of what seems like a
pointless comedy can demonstrate that
you need something more upbeat in your
life again different kinds of stories
for different times of acceptance
but that's all fine a good when reality
dips into fiction what about when
fiction dips into reality
what about one's trying to tell a true
story representing a person or people
that really existed tombstone the story
of Wyatt Earp I think is an awesome
movie but even I know it's highly
romanticized and made up quite a few
things to make the story more
entertaining isn't that sort of crossing
a line when you're actually depicting a
real person who existed saying that
scene for scene this is what happened in
his life well there has to be an
understanding that no film book or any
written story can fully capture a person
the goal is to capture the spirit of a
prison or an event because that's as
close as we can get that's why we never
say this is a true story instead that
it's based on the true story yes many
could get angry at the stuff that's made
up about these real-life people but for
others the focus is to capture a
person's spirit through some fiction and
emphasize their important actions
through a more comprehensive emotional
journey the importance to identify and
be with them throughout the entire
journey for many outweighs changing some
of the facts this naturally can backfire
as well I went out a big rant about
Michael Bay for not putting emphasis on
the men who died at Pearl Harbor when a
shocking fact that some of them couldn't
swim was just glanced over in a line
instead of being delve into likes a
Titanic delve into the shortage of
lifeboats
there were several scenes emphasizing
the poor safety of the Titanic so you
can understand the tragedy of the event
even better in Pearl Harbor is tossed to
the side so they can focus more on the
love triangle taking place with the
fictional characters that doesn't even
take place on Pearl Harbor this seemed
disrespectful because the fictional
characters in Titanic seem to help the
emotional connection with what the
people went through during that event
you remember so many of the real human
beings that were on the ship seeing them
through the eyes of the fictional
characters that you almost feel you've
become in Pearl Harbor I barely remember
any of the people who died and that's
missing the point of the story that's
when a real-life representation can go
too far when it doesn't capture the
focus or spirit of what the person or
event could represent the most
powerfully so we have
Aldi interpreting fiction and fiction
interpreting reality but that still
leaves the question when is a story just
a story and when is it more than a story
perhaps like anything in life the answer
is when you feel it can benefit you let
it benefit you and when you feel what
you're watching is nonsense
just let it be nonsense yes we've seen
many stories that we loved be butchered
over time but that doesn't mean the
strength of the original story isn't
there that doesn't mean you can't let it
impact you for the best just lets sink
in what you think is the most important
out of fiction that's what is there for
and yes it is good to analyze why a
story didn't work as it helps us
understand and appreciate why good
stories do how can you help others tell
better tales if you don't explain the
problems of the lesser ones yes
sometimes people can go up fit to fire
yeah but the more we show our passion
for the more we show how much it means
to us and if something means so much to
another person let it mean so much to
them don't force your opinion offer it
don't demand your voice be heard share
it movies can be so powerful if we let
them affect us in the right way but if
they consume you more than you consume
them then chances are you're not
choosing the healthy route so yes a
movie can just be a movie and it can be
something more depending on how you look
at it when it comes down to is what you
allow to have an impact on you and you
do have that choice to pick and choose
whatever makes you better
embrace it whatever makes you worse push
away it's like the song goes
the ESA's breeze and other science facts
it's just the show it's a give-and-take
trial and error process that can leave
you with the most fulfilling feeling
every time you take a trip to the movies
sometimes it's worth just leaving it as
background noise but other times it's
worth allowing it to leave its impact in
the best way you didn't even know
possible that's rap unless I don't think
it's good in which case it's crap I'm
the Nostalgia Critic I remember so you
don't have to
you